bonjour de quoi parle-t-on aujourd'hui
alors vous le savez j'aime bien qu'au
marché quand on tient bon jour de quoi
parle-t-on quand mais s'il y avait une
espèce de suspense mais non il n'y a pas
de suspense vous le savez vous avez
cliqué sur le titre de la vidéo on se
parle de ses smartphones là on se parle
aujourd'hui du au nord est du au nord
pourquoi parce que ses smartphones sont
intéressants parce que l'histoire qu'il
raconte est intéressant souvenez-vous il
ya quelques années au nord et huawei
s'est elle même groupe au nord est et la
marque jeune de huawei honor depuis
s'est séparé de huawei et a pu récupérer
les services google que huawei avait
perdu quelque temps auparavant donc
aujourd'hui au nord fait son grand
retour avec une gamme complète et autant
à une époque au nord est et la marque
jaune c'est à dire avec des produits
jeunes des produits entrée milieu de
gamme aujourd'hui mais sont dit on est
une marque indépendante on va voir une
gamme est extrêmement complète qui vous
est présenté le magic et le smartphone
pliable on a parlé il ya quelques temps
pouvait emmener avec moi barcelone je
vous ai montré le magic cap pro
consteste aura aussi un peu plus tard et
puis aujourd'hui je vous montre ses deux
nouveaux smartphones qui sont
intéressants parce qu'en fait c'est la
gamme x et la gamme x c'est quoi c'est
l'entraidé but du milieu de gamme de
chez aux doors alors pour autant vous
avez trois parties dans cette gamme vous
avez la gamme x que tu allais pour me
dire plutôt de l'entrée de gamme on a le
milieu de gamme avec la gamme avec un
numéro comme les honneurs 50 que je vous
ai également présenté l'année dernière
et puis la gamme magic c'est le haut de
gamme le magic quatre procès le
smartphone haut de gamme et le magic v
qui est le smartphone pliable voilà un
peu pour la photo de honor un instant t
donc on va regarder ces deux smartphones
on va regarder s'ils sont intéressants
s'ils sont faits pour vous s'il faut
venir se positionner quelle est la
différence parce qu'il ya deux produits
qui ont été présentés le au nord xe est
et le au nord xe suis alors j'ai les
tarifs je vous donne respectivement pour
vous savez tout chansons de postillonner
c'est dégueulasse donc je vous le dise
tout de suite mon papa il est pompier je
veux faire l'objectif le au nord xe est
sur le site d honneur il est à 199 90 et
celui là lone oryx utile à 239 euros 90
vous mais bien évidemment tous les liens
en bas dans la description pour vous
puissiez aller jeter un oeil et
découvrir ses jolis produits bon vous
est pris on va y aller au lit vago allez
c'est parti
[Musique]
oui
donc on aurait une vidéo qui est réalisé
en partenariat avec honneur parce qu'on
envoyait tient monsieur grehan on t'a
fait déjà testé des choses est ce que tu
voudrais tester de nouveaux smartphones
alors c'est vrai que j'ai testé des pc
d'honneur parce que au nord c'est pas
uniquement des smartphones sont des pc
ce sont différents produits éco système
une fois de plus cliquez sur le lien
d'un description pour aller voir leur
site web et tout découvrir donc j'ai
trouvé ça intéressant de venir voir ces
nouveaux produits vora croyait
ressembler et voir quelle était un peu
la différence entre les deux alors
regardez ça c'est la boîte du set le x
aide c'est celui-là luxe est il à défaut
aux airs duos nord 58 passes ils vous
sonnez sont vraiment au niveau du module
photo voiliers aux côtés au nord 50
alors il existe dans plusieurs couleurs
à tous les degrés dans les mêmes
couleurs en fait partie la couleur noir
est la couleur argent il ya la couleur
bleue moi j'ai deux noirs comme ça au
moins on peut comparer directement ici
on retrouve cet esprit duo nord 50 avec
ce module photo qui est assez sympa très
honnêtement grand capteur principal
qu'est la paix prévenant avec d'autres
mais je vous détaille ses rangs quelques
instants un smartphone qui lui
légèrement incurvé le capteur
d'empreintes digitales sur la tranche
qui les rouilles très rapidement vous
retrouvez une petite encoche légèrement
sur le haut un menton qui est pas trop
ouvrant sa voix sur les bords ils ont
vraiment bien travaillé et c'est quelque
chose qui est très sympa tandis que le
honor x8 celui là est bien hop le regard
des matchs comme ça lui il est beaucoup
plus plat vous avez un dos qui est plat
les côtés sont placardés la différence
de 2 x est qui est légèrement arrondi
lui il est quand même très très plat
c'est pas mal aussi un j'aime bien ce
design là alors au niveau du module
photo so far too qu'un peu plus sobre
avec quatre parties comme ça vous le
voyez vous avez quatre capteurs ok alors
ici on prend un peu la poussière et un
peu les traces de loin ces trucs un peu
relou donc mettez une coque de
protection déjà pour nous protéger et
puis en plus de ça ça vous évitera
toutes ces traces de doigt toute cette
poussière les j'aime bien ce design
assez plat tout ça c'est sympa
personnellement j'ai une préférence pour
le x8 versus le hic c'est que je trouve
encore plus épais mais dans les deux cas
les smartphones sont très sympas et sur
le x8 la différence que vous avez c'est
ici vous avez une petite peine encore à
ces espèces toute petite goutte en
points sont comme vous vous les voyez
ils ont vraiment voulu différencier les
deux modèles et je trouve que ça
fonctionne alors moi je vous le dis une
fois de plus mon coeur va venir pencher
davantage du côté du x8 pas parce qu'il
est plus cher et parce que j'aime bien
je préfère en tout cas le poinçon comme
ça et j'aime bien le côté hop là à
charge il cotait plat alors tiana ça
tombe bien qu'ils me montrent
qu'effectivement il venge de rechange
suis à 20 % parce que et c'est
intéressant dans ces deux smartphones
vous avez un bloc de charge qui inclut à
l'intérieur c'est du 22 5 watts c'est
lui donc c'est ce qu'on appellera à la
zone hors super de charges que vous avez
la travée d'un côté de l'usb à et de
l'autre côté de l'usbc ça vous l'aurez
charger assez rapidement en dix minutes
de charge vous reprenez 3 heures
d'autonomie donc ça c'est un truc qui
est assez rassurant et sur les deux
smartphones puisque on est au niveau de
la charge on va parler de la batterie
une différence en fait entre les deux
sur le x8 vous avez une batterie qu'un
peu plus petit c'est du quatre mille
millions terreur versus du à 5000
millions terreur sur le x est alors ce
qui est assez intéressant c'est qu'en
fait vous avez dans les deux produits
exactement le même processeur c'est dans
les deux cas le qualcomm snapdragon
c'est le 680,4 j'ai ici ce sont des
smartphones 4g ce ne sont pas des
smartphones s'engageait donc si vous
avez prévu de prendre un abonnement 5 g
sont pas ces smartphones là qu'il vous
faut donner au moins c'est là ça ne
laissez pas votre truc vous vous en
fichez et que vous voulez un bon rapport
qualité prix et que vous voulez un
smartphone et que les quatre génial si
vous avez de quoi faire et salir à
travers donc ce qui est intéressant
c'est que comme vous avez exactement le
même processeur d'un côté et de l'autre
et que vous avez une batterie qui est un
peu plus grosse sur le x7 versus le x8
et bien vous aurez une autonomie qui
sera un peu plus grand sur le x aide par
rapport aux x suite et il ya un autre
point qui va venir jouer aussi dans
cette question d'autonomie qui est
intéressante c'est que en fait dans les
deux cas vous avez un écran lcd sur le x
aide c'est un écran tft lcd ce que vous
avez une résolution ici en hd vous êtes
en combien de 1600 par 720 ici c'est du
full hd + 2388 c'est sa part 1080 on
aura une autonomie qui sera meilleur sur
le x est mais processeurs plus grosse
batterie plus fiable aux résolutions
vous emmènera un peu plus loin mais
comme je le dis dans les deux cas grâce
à la superbe charge ça devrait bien se
passer d'un côté comme de l'autre il ya
tout ce qu'ils ont fait qu'internet est
sûre les deux smartphones vous avez un
taux de rafraîchissement dynamique de 90
ans alors regardez je vous montre vous
venez dans vos paramètres ici vous venez
d'en affichage et luminosité et vous
venez d'en
fréquence c'est la regarder la fréquence
de rafraîchissement de l'écran dynamique
ça veut dire qu'en fait il si je veux
voir un taux de rafraîchissement qui va
être soit 2,61 soit 90 ans mais c'est
lui qui va le faire intelligemment on le
dit comme ça ouais je sais pas si je
vous préviens aujourd'hui c'est lui qui
le fait dynamiquement en tout cas mais
si vous voulez tout le temps sur les 90
s vous pouvez vous voulez j'ai
directement là sinon vous restez sur du
66 vous vous en fichez de montant 90 ans
je vous conseille le mode dynamique qui
va le gérer directement automatiquement
il le fera bien aux trucs à venir voir
et qui est intéressant sur ces deux
smartphones sur le paramètre mode est
température de couleur je les laissais
en maudit vif et en mode par défaut ici
la gare d'europe là par défaut ce qui me
fait un écran qui est plutôt bien que
fonctionnait plutôt bien terme de
calibrage calibration calibrage et puis
l'autre côté sur le xmb phantom hypo
différents comme n'est pas sur la même
dalle main sur du tfc ici j'ai un peu un
peu bidouillé mais pas grand-chose mode
des températures de couleur je suis
resté en couleurs vives et je lui
légèrement le réchauffé là alors je suis
pas passé en show parce que si je clique
en show là ça me tire légèrement sur le
verre voyez là et j'aime pas du tout
donc je viens le mettre là plus sur un
léger jaune orangé qui va venir casser
un côté un peu bleuté c'est bien
meilleur alors après il y en a en tout
cas savoir ces courriers sont des
smartphones qui sont certifiés lutter
contre la lumière bleue notamment grâce
à un mode confort des yeux pourrait
venir activés en permanence ça tire sur
un jeune a vraiment énorme énorme énorme
moi c'est parce que je vous recommande
il ya ça y est aussi le mode ebook qui
va venir lutter contre la lumière bleue
et contre la fatigue oculaire donc c'est
pas mal donc ça s'écoute en publie the
donc si vous voulez lire lire vous
mettez en ebook mais sinon le reste du
temps ce que je vous conseille c'est une
fois de plus vous venez dans votre
monnaie température de couleurs où elle
m'a fait ça je n'ai pas désactiver le
confort des yeux activé gel des actifs
voilà je me mets là et je reste bien ici
au plat et je le casse légèrement est là
pour monde en équilibre qui est bien et
ça fonctionnera bien puisque je vous
montre la partie logicielle ici c'est
magic ul 4.2 expérience propre au nord
c'est assez bien compréhensible grâce
aux différentes icônes que vous allez
avoir on se retrouve assez bien dans les
paramètres vos comptes système mise à
jour tout ce qui va être sécurité lee
privé bon là dessus le blu est propre et
bien fait donc ça fonctionnera et il n'y
a rien à redire autre truc qui est
intéressant est que nous a fait honneur
à une lumière qui m'a lâché c'est
celle-là au truc qui est intéressant est
que nous à fléchir réduire chargé de
lumière avenches pas pour rester par
charge et autres trucs qui intéresse en
juillet arrivée on a dans tous les cas
un écran de 6,74 pousse même taille
d'écran la chose qui va venir à être un
peu différente je voulais dit c'est
cette question de poinçon versus petite
encoche qu'on a ici la taille du menton
c'est quasiment la même donc on est
sensiblement sur le même format il est
un peu plus grand le donc on voit un peu
la différence garder au niveau des
bordures c'est des petites différences
de techno en fait un fabrication lui
c'est un peu plus fin je trouve que lui
est un peu mieux finie c'est vraiment ce
que je veux dire préférées mais bon il a
fallu faire des choix on est calme à
moins de 200 euros si sur le coup
ça n'impacte août à voir donc c'est
normal qu'on ait vraiment cette
différence ici à notre truc qui est
aussi super intéressant c'est que dans
un cas comme dans l'autre ils nous ont
laissé une prise directe donc si vous
voulez venir un brancher un casque pour
maximiser l'expérience audio gars vous
pouvez venir le faire donc ça c'est cool
à savoir également si vous n'avez qu'un
haut parleur mono mais c'est normal
smartphone d'entrée de gamme haut
parleur mono qui situe ici d'un côté
l'autre c'est préoccupant du monde on
s'en doutera mais ça fonctionne et le
différence quand même d'y retrouver
c'est au niveau des photos alors
regardez là vous avez sur le un capteur
de 48 mégapixels sur le grand-angle
tandis que sur les connaisseurs du 64
mégapixels sur le grand-angle après
c'est la même chose ultra grand-angle de
5 mégapixels et d'un capteur de
profondeur à un capteur de maquereaux
ici au nord nous a rien dit dans la
fiche technique je suppose qu'on a des
capteur de 2 mégapixels d'un côté deux
autres paraîtrait assez logique vous
montrer les résultats dans quelques
instants côté photo et côté caméra de
celle filles on retrouve sur le un
capteur de 8 mégapixels tandis que sur
lui comme un capteur de 16 mégapixels
bon ok ça c'est sur le papier regardez
justement les photos prises on commence
par le mi6 bon c'est pas mal c'est
correct ça fonctionne attention
néanmoins de 200 euros donc on va pas
avoir des exigences de dengue sur ce
smartphone là sur des photos un peu
souvenirs classique sur votre grand
temps que l'on fera des choses pas trop
mal je vous montre un ultra grand angle
en une très grosse différence de
colorimétrie puis beaucoup moins précis
mais une fois de plus c'est normal à
noter que sur aucun capteur vous n'avez
une stabilisation optique ce qui est
aussi normal à ce tarif là donc bon
luttera canton dont pourra faire des
choses mais ce n'est pas tout que plus
dingue on peut venir nous met enfin deux
bombes a tout de suite qu'il ya un petit
correction logicielle qui vient un peu
poussé les traits qu'il est un peu sur
contrastées c'est pas parfait c'est
normal et on peut aller jusqu'en fin
huit bons faut-il aller jusqu'au fond 8
la réponse est clairement non grand
angle et ses soutiens à côté qui est un
peu je serai pas comment vous décrire
cela comme s'il y avait une espèce de
folie sage mais qui globalement
fonctionne quand même pas trop mal on
peut sortir des clichés souvenirs qui
seront assez correct regardez-le ultra
grand angle là je vous dis une fois que
tu joues un peu la même chose beaucoup
moins précis mais bon voilà on a moins
de sens mal faille à un moment il faut
garder un peu les pieds sur terre la
même chose ici au sortir des souvenirs
de voyages avec des amis on fait des
photos qui seront corrects je vous
conseille vraiment de rester sur votre
capteur principal est de ne pas venir
vous amuser avec le reste parce que
c'est pas parfait mais c'est normal on
peut venir faire aussi un peu de
maquereaux une distance de 4 cm je suis
pas du tout fan de la macro sur les
capteur de 2 mégapixels donc beau jeu ça
va être bien meilleures ici déjà il faut
trouver la bonne distance et puis voilà
on sort des choses quoi mais bon faut-il
le faire je sais pas convaincu caméra de
celle fils est sensiblement la même
chose on peut avoir quelques souvenirs
j'ai une vraie gueule d'enterrement ça
c'est merci et pollen regarder
les valoches sous les yeux mais bon
voilà on peut faire des petites choses
c'est pas mal mais ça fonctionne le
capteur du sera un peu meilleur on peut
faire des choses un peu mieux y'a pas
une grosse révolution entre les deux on
reste un peu dans la même lignée mais
c'est un petit poil au dessus on a
également l'ultra grand angle c'est le
même résultat on peut venir ou non en x
2 x huit on en oublie voyez c'est un peu
la même idée je trouve au niveau du
traitement des photos retrouve un peu de
ce mets l'aspect entre le x7 et le x 8 x
j'inverse 1 sat xxl d'enseignants x7 et
x8 désolé des fois pour la version voyez
c'est raconte un peu la même histoire en
fait je suis bien mis mer au même
endroit plus qu'on s'en contre fout
d'ailleurs bien côté un peu plus dé
saturer sur le x8 versus le x7 sur le
capteur principal sur le grand angle
toujours les mêmes choses sur la macro
parce que ça sera ça sera le même truc
on va voir sensiblement les mêmes photos
bon voilà c'est pas tout mais bon on
arrivera à faire des petites choses un
peu marrante si on aime ça mais je ne
suis pas du tout convaincu dans les
usages et puis la caméra de celle fille
même si on a deux fois plus de
mégapixels et bien je dirais que c'est
un peu la même chose c'est pas top top
top donc considérer vraiment qu'en photo
on peut faire des choses sympas sur les
souvenirs ce mode capteur principal
gérer c'est le point essentiel alors en
conclusion qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir
de smartphones de prix qui sont quand
même très très proche ajout dit il ya 40
euros d'écart entre les deux prix alors
40 euros quand on est sur un tarif entre
200 et 240 euros ça fait quand même un
peu d'argent 199 euros 90 et 239 90 je
pense que au nord vous m'en voudrez pas
de dire qu'on a quasiment 200 et 240
euros avec 40 euros dès 4 ans est plutôt
clair alors c'est beaucoup d'argent
effectivement 40 euros sur cette gamme
de prix là mais pour autant moi ce que
je vous conseille plus plus plus c'est
d'aller sur le x8 bien évidemment il en
fera un peu plus bien évidemment il y en
aura un peu plus sous le capot mais
surtout parce que j'aime bien avec le x8
c'est ce design qui est quand même un
peu différent j'aime bien ces lignes je
trouve un peu plus fin je trouve un peu
plus élégant je trouve que le x7 il est
pas trop mal bond c'est déjà un peu plus
vues pour qui la côte est plus premium
le x8 et j'ai encore lancé un espèce de
postillons et d'enfin que je me suis
reid rade je crois aujourd'hui capteur
d'empreintes digitales fonctionne bien
on a un loup qui est bon on a ce petit
point sont qui reste très discret et qui
fonctionne bref on a smartphones qui est
très cool à 240 euros et puis d'ailleurs
allé voir sur le site de au nord parce
que dans en temps il ya des choses
intéressantes pour tenir le 3 dans les
meilleures conditions ou alors des
paquets et ça c'est plutôt pas mal donc
on a deux afin de cool si ces 40 euros
de delta et bien c'est énorme pour vous
pouvez aller sur le x est il aura une
batterie plus grosse l'autonomie vous
emmènera un poil plus loin mais le x8
est quand même plutôt bien sachez que
vous avez quand même un chargeur de 25
quads donc on va venir recharger assez
rapidement donc ça fonctionnera bien et
pas de stress là dessus deux produits
que moi je trouve intéressant et puis il
se trouve vraiment intéressant c'est le
retour de honor avec les services google
avec une gamme qui va s'étendre ça veut
donc dire que honore sa d'acteurs sur
lequel il faut compter il va falloir
compter plus plus plus plus plus dans
les temps à venir avec une grande gamme
qui va se développer avec une cohérence
et de plus en plus de produits et ça je
trouve ça vachement intéressant pourquoi
est-ce que ça c'est pour le bénéfice du
consommateur alors maintenant dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez est-ce que
vous avez déjà eu un smartphone d'odeurs
peut-être d'ailleurs avez-vous un
smartphone théodore est ce que vous avez
à 11h50 peut-être peut-être pas dire
dites le moi juste en bas en commentaire
et puis est ce que vous pourriez vous
laisser tenter par ces deux smartphones
le x7 et le xvid dites le moi en bas
nous on se retrouve très vite pour
continuer à parler tech bien évidemment
et parler d'eux au nord parce qu'on
reviendra bientôt le magic cap pro que
je vous ai déjà présenté on regardera ça
parce que nous allions c'est vachement
intéressant il a fait très jolies
promesses notamment pour faire la photo
de la vidéo c'est tout autre histoire
attention c'est beaucoup plus cher si
vous voulez du au nord car il beaucoup
plus abordable ça se passe ici mais
aussi très chaud les choses à raconter
dans le haut de gamme sonore et ça c'est
bien aller pour les soins 12 embrassant
bientôt
[Musique]